[Music]
what's going on man can you everyone can
can you everyone hear me fine do I sound
good can you hear me that's the question
DK yes sir can you hear me actually it
don't even really matter if the chat
can't hear me matters if DK can hear me
because he's the one I'm doing the show
with what's going on D how how's your
how's your afternoon been it's been cool
man very interesting week got a lot to
talk about my brother oh yeah it's it's
it's uh normally the the you know I
ain't G to lie you know I enjoy taking
the the occasional shots on
um occasional shots on on Playstation
but today we G have to load uh load the
chamber up a little bit for Xbox what's
going on you guys welcome back to the as
we talk about the past present future
gaming got my co speak dirt green what's
going on dirt what you been playing oh
man for some reason I I just
finished Kan the Lynch like the second
cany Lynch you know I've been playing
some older games um but I have went back
to cyber Punk CU I never did finish that
game so I said let me you know while
there's nothing right now popping new
let me go back to my back log so I've
been playing cyberp
Punk with the expansion and all that no
no I no I'm playing the base game
because I haven't even you know I only
put like maybe five or six hours into
that game all all together so I said let
me go ahead and put my focus in this
game for a minute yeah I went back to
playing kany Lynch man because I like I
was saying I was my game playay on my
videos for like a couple months like it
was always Call of Duty and um you know
Allan Wake I said let me get some old
game footage some you know some stuff
like that so I just start playing some
day and I actually finished the C Lynch
game again the the second one it was
kind of trash though I'm I even know
what the Kanan Lynch
is you don't remember Kanan Lynch from
the 360 generation no no don't damn you
was playing jpgs wasn't you
yeah I don't even I I don't even vely
remember what you're talking about see
is it like I interactive game I
interactive they remember that too like
I like the people that made hit man you
know oh okay
yeah I interactive man I haven heard
that name in a while they're working on
that XBox exclusive right the dragon
game or whatever yeah it's crazy we
might get right and James Bond gang yeah
yeah that's right James
[Music]
Bond oh my God all right what's going on
you guys uh I've been playing um what
have I been playing I've been playing a
lot of Halo infinite like a ridiculous
amount of Halo
infinite actually really really vibing
of Halo infinite o been playing a lot of
Li of P I've been streaming it uh you
know tonight I'll be streaming Liza P
after the podcast and the first boss was
easy the second boss was pretty easy but
the third boss give me a little issues
it's not
necessarily I can't beat him I'm
stubborn I like dodging I don't like I
don't like paing oh pairing right and
this boss is highly encourag encouraged
that you dog that you parry everything
that's thrown at you so it's been like a
little bit of a uh you know a little bit
of a learning curve I almost beat him
yesterday I came this close to beating
him uh but he he he came triumph over me
so you if you guys want to see me
struggle a little bit more uh after the
show over there on the ad Arena Channel
I will be streaming that uh but what
we're going to get into man we're going
to just jump straight into it man you
know one thing that I want to really
point out
is regardless how we feel about like the
third party stuff and we'll get into
that here uh you know
momentarily no one can
deny that
2024 for Xbox looks insane what do you
think about D what's some of the moments
that got your eye that got you over
there look in at
2024 well I would say it started and um
December when like they show hellblade
to some gameplay footage some some
combat I like whoa that game was
incredible one of the best looking games
of this generation I would be honest
whoa so that so knowing that that game
was dropping this year and also a v
dropping this year those are two games
I'm I'm really looking forward to but
then of course with yesterday's
announcement to know the Indiana Jones
is coming this
year you yeah that's that's a pretty
good lineup among other games you know
uh you know like some of the third party
or second party games they have like
stalker and man this is that's a pretty
strong lineup bro pretty strong lineup
yeah I think um when it comes to 2024
we'll get into more of the direct uh but
even like DLC wise games as a service
wise new IP wise sequel wise like it's
kind of insane like it really is so
toborn hellblade looks like Indiana
Jones is coming this year yeah I forgot
about toborn yeah yeah and what's funny
is like you know when we get to the
developer act you know people expect
what are you doing with the shadow drop
so you know I don't know why people keep
saying imagine they Shadow drop Indiana
Jones they are not Shadow dropping
Indiana Jones I think I think we need to
stop with the shadow drop though I mean
just because they did it last year
doesn't mean they're gonna do it this
year that doesn't establish a pattern
you know we we we got to see it at least
twice to think it's even remotely a
pattern now they might Shadow drop
something yeah but they're never gonna
Shadow drop a triaa game like that it
never be a smaller game you know Tower
borne can get Shadow Dro it could
because Tower borne's supposed to come
out relatively soon and it wasn't part
of that list right so they might say
that's out after the show I don't know
know uh but you know it's it's
interesting you know I think Xbox 2024
CU I think 2023 was good in terms of of
product in terms of gains but I don't
think they had a lot of Heavy Hitters
besides Starfield I think stuff like
Forza Miss missed the beat in a lot of
ways but I don't think it nothing in
2023 besides Starfield move the needle I
think me personally just a vow and
hellblade and Indiana Jones they all
individually move the needle so you know
it's it's going to be good man you know
I I think this year it's going to be a
pretty relevant year with uh with with
Xbox in general I agree with you I agree
I agree with everything you say even
about 2023 I think Starfield is the only
game that really moved the needle even
though highi Rush was a hell of a
surprise a great game I wouldn't say it
moved the needle either but but
Starfield you know that definitely moved
the needle but but yeah I agree with you
I think high five Rush got people's
attention I don't think it mov the
needle yeah I do think there's a
difference
yeah all right so you know obviously you
know when it comes to 2024 uh what what
is your highlight and your expectation
what's the game that you're looking
forward to most in
2024 well um like I said H hail Blade 2
is that game because I was around on the
Xbox one generation where Xbox had a lot
of cartoony looking games you know and
some of us with the Xbox One X we was
like yo listen look man we got this
super powerful console gears 5 looks
incredible but we need to see some other
you know first party games you know we
know like we had Red Dead Redemption 2
that looked incredible there was some
games look incredible I was like man I
wish Xbox really had a game a first
party game besides gears and you know
Foresta games to show off the power of
these powerful
consoles and Hell blade to is that game
you can deny it I saw people saying it's
blurry you a damn liar you're a liar
they got
C they got cataracts that's why blurry
saying hey add I saw people saying man
[__] hell blur it's blurry it's blurry
shut up that game looks incredible so
incredible that these people get their
eyes CHS that Insomniac actually said
this is a you
know like uh like a good point hellblade
was such a a captivating you know
uh you know Candy ey type of game that
insomnia said we want that they said
we're that's our goal you know I forgot
the words they use exactly but they said
we want wber rine to to have that uh
that graphical fored you know what I'm
saying that game looks incredible man
you can try to say it doesn't I don't
want to hear it it looks incredible and
notice I'm s didn't say we want to look
like Nai
dog hey that's adct being messy that's
not me guys I didn't know but I mean
what where was the naughty dog needs to
you know we we need to look like Last of
Us Part Two because that's a very
impressive looking game why didn't they
want to be compared to
them damn it's it kind kind of feels
like insaniac lowkey over there
comparing themel like the visually they
want to look like hell play I'm just
saying I'm just saying thank you uh Duke
too the visual Benchmark that's what
they said the visual
Benchmark um they want to look like
hellblade that's all that matters yeah
and Hell blade looks good you know I I
don't think hellblade's gonna really
push me hellblade is definitely I look
at hellblade as
like one of the most important games on
Xbox to show when they buy Studio they
elevate that [__] M uh you know you can
argue that hellblade's the first big
game that came out of that 2018 Studios
out of 2018 absolutely uh so we're gonna
have to see exactly how that is because
regardless how I feel like a lot of
Starfield post uh main production was
under Xbox you can make an argument the
saying it
wasn't
so hellblade
2 was produced entirely under Xbox
so you can see
exactly what Xbox does in terms of
getting this stuff coming out uh I also
believe
that Xbox has a lot of faith in in
hellblade because they chose to show
hellblade to reveal the series
X you know they could have did it with a
variety of other games but they chose
hellblade and I think the reason they
chose hellblade is because hellblade
supposed supposed to be this is what our
games can look like on this
platform because
they oh I'm sorry sorry they just
dropped a random YouTube video for the
series
s you know they chose a game to show
with the series
X yeah what was you gonna say I was
about to say and and they also showed
the game off several times um you know
it was in at the game awards for three
separate years because think about 20 21
even though the game was clearly still
years away they showed a nice gameplay
slice um like you just mentioned they
they um announced the Xbox series X with
hellblade to you said there's some trust
there they trust Ninja Theory because
sometimes if a company show off a game
too early at especially in today's time
they show off a game five years early
and there's not always a guarantee that
game is going to release with you know
turnover in the industry so many issues
with some of these games so there's a
trust with Ninja Theory like you just
said ad I didn't think about it like
that but you're absolutely right they
trust Ninja Theory they have faith in
hail blade too and I think the game is
going to be that game that make people
say yo I ain't know Xbox had this in
them as far as a first party game
looking that impressive so I'm do you
think like you know let's move our
attention a little bit over to Indiana
Jones how how graphically intense you
think Indiana Jones is going to look
because I think machine games has always
made very you know captivating looking
games I'm glad you asked me that because
um I believe the Wolfenstein games were
underrated for his Graphics the games
look great man I don't know if y'all in
the or has played those Wolfenstein
games those games look great and uh we
still don't know if Indiana Zone's going
to be first person or third person or
even a combination of both but I'm
pretty sure the graphics are going to be
amazing because Wolfenstein games look
dope good dope dope story great voice
acting I can't wait to see man I can't
wait to see will it have Harrison for
likeness that's a question maybe not I
think it will I think it will because I
think most Indiana Jones games had
Harrison Ford likeness I mean at least
on the cover besides the Lego G it makes
no it makes no sense to to not do it and
not have his likeness yeah I mean maybe
like he won't voice it but I don't know
that's a good question will they have
his likeness because I every game I can
think of except for the Lego games of
course had Harrison Ford on the damn
cover even the ones from Atari the the
the Super Nintendo those games I think
there's a lot of things you can argue I
don't think you can argue saying that
Harrison like Harrison Ford is Indiana
Jones He is Indiana Jones 100% you can't
have him that might be in his contract
you know what I'm saying that might be
in his contract if you say indana Jones
it's me show my face I don't know you
know I'm just speculating
but all
right
AAL what kind of expectations you have
on a Val um I don't really know because
we don't know much about the game the
only thing I can go bu is the studio I
love obsidian I love like their their
their last game well I don't really play
grounded but as far as their RPGs their
I love the outter worlds I finished that
game so I'm excited for that game also
because it's obsidian don't know much
about a v that's why we're looking
forward to next week I'm definitely
looking forward to next week to um see
more of that game but yeah I think the
game looks fine I know like they changed
it or whatever but it still looks pretty
good to me so I'm definitely looking
forward to that game
also I think a V's going to be a Hidden
Gem this year I think it's going to get
a similar kind of reception maybe a
little bit more that the outer worlds to
got I mean the outer worlds
got I'm just curious how big it gets
that's my biggest curiosity when it
comes that's a good question because the
out of Wars was not a long game it a RPG
but it was only about what 25 hours long
maybe 30 a lot of people appreciate I
was okay with that I was just about to
say that I was okay with that because I
was able to finish the game and didn't
feel like I stayed too long you know um
so I actually like that every game
doesn't need to be a Starfield or
Assassin's Creed Val Halla or super dup
long games a witch or three every game
every RPG doesn't need to be
that we'll have to see I think um I
think this year is going to be a solid
experience for Xbox I just hope the
games come out and deliver what they're
supposed to and I think for the most
part they will I think it will too let's
move on
to Xbox going third
party all right I'm I'mma give you the
floor for like two or three minutes
talking about this because I'm curious
to hear your opinion and I have to eat a
couple bites of this or I'm about to die
of exhaust right so man about the third
party thing what I want your biggest
thing is I I want your opinion on the
rumors in general if they're valid I
want your opinion on whether or not what
games will go and I want your opinion on
the long-term of things and what happens
if you put games even is as smaller
titles like high five Rush on Nintendo
and Playstation is that going to mean
anything and I want to know do you think
it's not cuz King's mindset is if it's
Nintendo we good that's what his mindset
is as long as it's just Nintendo we good
and I want your opinion on that as
well um well first off when I first
heard the rumor I was kind of like uh
you
know you know then you kind of calm down
after a couple of days you know you say
tell if high five Rush goes see if
thieves goes I didn't even like see if
thieves I love high five rush though you
you um you don't want your favorite
platform first party games going to
other platforms but then again this is
it's kind of crazy to say man it's like
we have PlayStation have a couple of
their games on Xbox obviously Xbox have
a few games on
PlayStation they have a good
relationship with Nintendo so kind of
like no I don't wanted to go over there
then again I'm like those smaller games
doesn't bother me too much you know no
smaller games like high five Rush even
the CF thieves it's a bigger game but
it's still not a game it's a game that
you know who cares the game is six years
old even though we still get steady
content so I I went back and forth then
this is the question that I
have if they let a few of these smaller
games go
which is fine go ahead will it open up
doors to bigger games now if it opened
up doors to Halo or or something like
that then I'm like come on now that's
our franchise you know that's our that's
our flagships we don't want gears over
there because they ain't gonna give us
God of War or anything like that and you
know I and I believe in exclusives I I I
think exclusives are important you think
about everything has some exclusivity
attached to it for the most part right
I mean you're not going to get a for
expedition you're not going to get a
Chrysler Expedition they're going to
have their own they got their own [__]
they got a you know the the the the the
Dodge Durango or whatever else vehicle
they they have their own stuff so I
don't
want it to be a habit I understand
there's exceptions we know there's
exceptions they bought a couple of
Publishers right we know there's
exceptions with Minecraft with Call of
Duty maybe some games in the future some
games as a service might go to other
platforms I get it I get it but what I'm
not going to do is completely lose my
damn mind and cuss Xbox the hell out
because in my opinion it's all console
war stuff as somebody who is engaged in
a council War This Is counil War
ammunition that's why I think some
people are pissed off about it you know
like like I said damn if they let the
gangs go over there Pony's gonna be
talking mad [__] so that's most of the
reason I think some guys are upset right
I do think that you you know even take
away the console
stuff there's a reason PlayStation and
switch do so well because they have
captivating titles keeping their
consumers on that platform and I think
when you finally get something as solid
as Hi-Fi
rush and even though it's a smaller
title it is a good title and it's a
great title
I get it you know it probably didn't
sell the greatest because of like you
know stuff like Game Pass being Shadow
dropped I heard it didn't even sell
million on Steam I don't know if that's
true or not so it's just like I get it
but at the same time it's like
you dug this bed not us and to
me it's not a good
look if XBox doesn't push exclusive
stuff to make their Hardware appealing
because what gets people generally over
at of Hardware it's marketing deals and
exclusives my
concern is we've had a bad habit this
generation of people just straight out
refusing to Port their con their game
over to to the play Xbox I feel like
this isn't going to help the console
sales very much and that's going to get
worse um I understand what you're saying
um I go back to this high-f five Rush uh
while an incredible
game it's not a flagship game not yet
maybe it could be later and I understand
um you know people wanted to stay
exclusive I just feel
that if if XBox start putting their
Flagship franchises on other platforms
now we have a problem you know because
you think about in 2016 when Xbox was
the first ones to start doing PC day and
day people said they're crazy they're
out of their damn
mind now people understand why they did
it but at the same
time I don't I don't want their big
games going like some of their smaller
games I me personally I'm just speaking
for me I don't care you know I don't
care to see if these is going there six
years later going to
Nintendo now I will
say what will
PlayStation and and like Nintendo do for
Xbox that's a question I would like to
know not a damn
thing see that's that's the thing that
bothers me a little bit you know what
I'm saying the issue I
have
is PlayStation going to get 30% of
everything they sell with high five Rush
hey D what do you think they're gonna do
with that money in invest in their
stuff to lock more games off of Xbox
yeah you're literally giving them
finances to [__] on your consumer base
because that's what they've been
notorious for doing they do it every
year and you're giving them more
finances to do it
more
I mean yeah I yeah that's true they do
pay to keep a lot of stuff off of Xbox
um you know this is like this man you
know this is a situation that you know
you just like you just don't know what's
going to happen you know we might have
heard things we might have heard rumors
from people that usually know what's
going on and they might be right um so
all I can say is if this
happens a couple of small Xbox
games yeah I'm I don't like it I'm not
going to jump ship like some other guys
were sounding like they were going to do
Monday I don't like it uh but you know
it is what it is I just don't want it to
go further than
that and that's the the thing that's the
question right we don't know where one
ends and one begins
yeah yep so
yeah I mean that's true that's that's
that's a fair point do you think Xbox
gets out of the console Market if they
go third
party if they go full third
party yes you mean full third part full
third
party at that point I still don't think
so
um you know what I don't know if they go
not full third party usually means
they're going to stop making consoles I
don't think they're going to go full
thir party I still see games like V
hellblade and and gears to you know as
exclusives in you know in the future
moving forward I don't see him going
full a third party like not making
consoles anymore N I don't see that not
20 years from now will there be cils who
the hell knows by then I'll be in my 60s
do you think that them doing this cuz
Phil came out openly and said we go
wherever Game Pass is MH Game Pass is is
in coming to these other platforms yeah
do you think they might be stepping away
from supporting Game Pass as much as
they
[Music]
were I thought Game Pass was the rout to
all of these Acquisitions so you know if
if game if they're stepping away from
Game Pass eventually what was the
purpose for all of these
Acquisitions was all of it mobile I
understand ABK was mobile but what about
with that what was that about I feel you
but what's the point in putting games on
another platform that game pass doesn't
exist cuz then they can just buy there
they don't have to get Game Pass or your
console yeah I I I don't
know I don't know about all that sounds
a little bit too too
much like I mean I just I just can't see
all
that them stepping away from Game Pass
and Game Pass is probably at what 30
million I didn't say stepping away I
meant more like pulling back as
much pulling back you mean like what
stop focusing on Game Pass stop putting
a spotlight on it maybe we put a
spotlight on the whole ecosystem and
Game Pass are just part of
it I don't
know I don't know about that one bro
okay
so I'mma jump and get the Super Chat uh
L uh luro to Paul said $2 super I
appreciate say where's the official
announcement stop it do you agree that
we should report on stuff before it's
been officially
confirmed yeah I mean it's it's cool to
have a conversation part of part of like
the reason I was like kind of like why
these guys so upset about it is because
it's not official yet we can have
discussions but some guys are losing the
damn mind over
it yeah it's one thing to speculate it's
another thing to act like it's conf
confirmed yeah now when it's
confirmed like when Xbox had raised the
price of the Xbox
Live I was
pissed because that was confirmed that
came from them that was confirmed but
right now it's still you know
speculation and stuff rumors I feel like
if you're going on Twitter or making
videos just being very genuine about
that you would want that you don't think
this is a good direction for Xbox that's
fair criticism and I think that's good
uh but if you're going out there acting
like this is genuine and this is going
to happen we don't know what's going to
happen uh we have no idea yeah we
don't like I saw somebody
um losing on Twitter man like like like
even the direct was announcing they was
like pissed off like is this gonna be a
third third party show and blah blah
blah a man come on
man listen these companies are going to
do what they're going to do anyway but
as far as
discussion we all like us podcast we
talk about you know rumors we talk about
speculation that's what we do but I
believe sometime
reactions are something you know we need
to be careful with well part of
me wants to push back th a little bit
because I do think let's say this Israel
there's a chance that Microsoft sees the
push back on the industry the push back
on the fans
and they could potentially reverse this
decision yeah I personally feel like us
speaking out when it's confirmed at that
point it's too late there's no reversing
that
right that's just my opinion on the
matter I mean you know there's
exceptions like the esbo Live Gold thing
that was official and it was we pushed
back and they change but that's easy to
push back we're talking about developing
a game true true true by the time the
game comes out or officially announced
and let's say it's like three or four
months from now the game's essentially
almost dumb yeah and at that point
they're not gonna get all that money
away because it's gonna hurt them more
than help them yeah well you know what
at the at the end of the day could this
high-fi Rush C if these rumor be true
yeah of course it could be true um but I
don't think just me personally I don't
think going to go for third party um I
believe Nintendo if we're hearing the
rumor about the Nintendo uh switch 2 um
specs 64 gigabytes now it's just rumors
but the rumor is gonna have 64 gigabytes
of storage bro I mean it ain't too many
more game like unless they rely on
streaming like they did for some games
with the switch but it's kind of like
come on man um you know if it's just
only going to be a PlayStation future
no I just don't see that Xbox is already
going to make the next Xbox or whatever
console and I still do believe console
um is is a big part of the ecosystem I
know people say they don't care about
consoles I believe they do but it's not
the only thing that're they're trying to
sell you I believe consoles uh will be
around I definitely I think another 15
years after the next iteration of Xbox
after that I don't know I believe the
technology might be so Good by then you
can probably somehow stream the from
your phone to the TV I don't know you
know like who knows what's going to
happen 15 to 20 years from now but I do
believe consoles is Step definitely in
their future for at least the next the
next the next iteration of the
Xbox yeah so I mean when it comes down
to me man I just want what's best for
the
brand I can only go off of my opinion
covering this industry my opinion
talking about this industry um one thing
I won't do is me
personally anyone that wants to chime in
on this even if they're going to the
extreme saying it's approved I'm okay
with because like I've seen time and
time
again I personally
feel that voting me through wallet is is
is is definitely a solid thing you can
do but
throughout the
years I've seen too many
people vote with their wall and still
nothing happened because there's still
plenty of casual audience that just
doesn't know what's going on they're not
keeping up so to
me being respectful and giving your
criticism is always going to be more
effective you know the majority of the
big big turnarounds in gaming Industries
happened before the product even came
out uh you know the the Xbox One
revision before they even saw a penny of
that money uh Battlefront to before they
saw even a penny of that money the the
Xbox raising the prices which they
didn't they didn't raise the prices
technically they stopped giving you
discounts on buying it in bulk so used
to be you buy 12 months of Xbox Live you
got it 50% off for buying all of that up
front uh they stopped giving you that
that uh that
discount
technically it's not a price increase
but it's still not
right we got that reversed and there
wasn't there wasn't any money
exchange because I personally feel a
community manager Phil
Spencer people getting on on
Twitter and seeing 20 plus notifications
20 plus notifications 20 plus
notifications and they see not only
because what's that going to lead to
it's going to lead to
wallet we can skip all of that
[__] by vocalizing our opinion on social
media don't do it in a disrespectful way
because they ain't going to Care at that
point if you go out there and you say
some off-the-wall crazy ass [__] then
they're not going to take you seriously
and you just wasted your time but you go
on there like look these are the reasons
I feel like this isn't good for the
brand and I personally feel like this
isn't going to go you get a couple
hundred people saying that now people
saying they're gonna stop playing games
that's
nonsense I will never stop playing games
even if XBox went away tomorrow I'm
still gonna play games but I do think
it's very healthy to V voice your
opinion on stuff that's why I cover
rumors I cover speculation cover all
that stuff and people say well why are
you talking about this addict it's not
confirmed it's like it's that earlier
because I personally feel like if I
waited till it was confirmed to make a
video it's too late ain't nothing can be
done ain't nothing could be
reversed it's
happening well you know one thing that
does bother me I'm I'm going to say we
we heard at the FTC
trial that Indiana Jones was going to be
a multiplatform game because it was
developed by
bethesa Microsoft after the acquisition
said yo make it
exclusive so when you hear these types
of
rumors then you hear something that's
100% true because they said it under
oath at court that Indiana Jones is a
XBox exclusive Xbox and PC exclusive and
they made it that way then you look like
damn so we heard this last year I'm sure
that took place years ago but we heard
this last year from from P Hines that
Indiana Jones was a multiplat now is an
XBox exclusive because Phil or whoever
made the decision to make an exclusive
then you're hearing over
here some of their games are going to go
multiplatform so I'm like okay some of
their games going
multiplatform I can believe it because
they already have some games on on other
consoles but then you have on the other
side they're making deals to keep games
exclusive a bigger triaa game a license
game they want to make it exclusive so
you're kind of
like you know I don't know I don't know
bro I'm kind of like okay do you think
that
[Music]
um I can't hear you bro is that better
yeah you kind of breaking up a little
bit I'm breaking up oh no you good now
you good now all right do you think
games like CES is is okay to do it with
or like how do you feel about games as a
service okay that actually would benefit
from having a bigger player base because
I do think there's an argument there
like stuff like cfds I'm cool if that
goes to PlayStation because I feel like
that's better for that game for for the
for the model some games as service I
can see that happening yeah but games
like highi Rush
I don't think that's good to do anything
with I personally don't think high five
Rush is going to sell that well on
PlayStation and switch you know there
was um chain something I can't remember
what it was it was a switch game that
was mad sucessful Astro
chain extremely good game love people
loved it I didn't really played a whole
lot myself people loved it that sucker
didn't do nothing on on switch so it's
just like I think Xbox for a company
that does so much long-term thinking
we're gonna we're gonna drop 70 Bill 70
Bill Stacks right now this is a
long-term uh you know investment this
seems like some very shortterm
moves yeah I mean I don't know I don't
know we'll see what happen bro we'll see
what
happen yeah so say Astro chain so well
man yeah I just got to the point
where
I I just wanted it to do good
yeah
if if if if Microsoft and Xbox I
generally thought there was something to
do in here I would be a little bit more
open-minded to it but I'm sitting here
looking at it and I'm just like people
say well are do you are you a billion a
trillion dollar company no but a
trillion dollar company dropped the ball
mixer a trillion dollar company dropped
the ball on the Windows Phone a trillion
dollar company Dr drop the ball on mix
on mixer though didn't they
try they dropped the bag they tried to
compete and they just couldn't but that
that's my point it's just like these
these multi-billion trillion dollar
companies they're not always right
either yeah
you know why because it's humans making
a decision so of course they're not
always right you know um there was you
know of course they're not always right
so let me ask you this and we'll move on
to uh the the direct because I want to
really talk about that with you if this
is true and we see Hi-Fi Rush uh you
know slide into PlayStation
TFS um first off let's go back real
quick because I don't think because I
was eating I apologize for that I never
eat on stream but I didn't eat my
brothers ring me food I had to eat I was
about to pass out um do you think it's
okay if it goes to Nintendo not
PlayStation do I think it's okay yeah of
course so you you think that it's
because I I'm on that too I think it
shouldn't go anywhere but I do think it
going to Nintendo is is less
impactful it's definitely less impact
Xbox yeah because PlayStation like we
mentioned already has paid to keep games
off of
Xbox what has Nintendo done with
Bayonetta maybe I don't know that's I
they made that game in exclusive
so no Joey I no I don't think it's okay
but I would prefer to go Nintendo than
PlayStation I actually prefer to go
anywhere a PlayStation that's just I
guess like you know I just played
octopot travel to on on on Playstation
been a phenomenal game and I'm just
sitting here and I'm like even though
that we're getting this now it's hard
for me not to 100% think that
PlayStation had nothing to do with that
I have to answer my phone uh take over
for a second yeah
um we all know that PlayStation and
Square Enix has these this relationship
and they missigned so many deals to keep
off of Xbox the FTC trial also exposed
that they pay to keep games out of Game
Pass pay to keep games off of
Xbox so I would prefer high five Rush
not go to neither PlayStation or
Nintendo but to be honest if it went to
Nintendo I wouldn't be upset about it
yeah K King says it's a reward for not
uh blocking the uh FTC though yeah I
heard him I heard him say something it's
like a reor that me yeah I heard him say
that it's funny but you know it is what
it is man all right so it's my last
question with this topic let's say this
does happen we see we see play St let me
let me finish my statement before before
you say anything because I know you're
gonna wantan to You're Gonna Want to
intervene and that's fine because I had
interrupted myself a long time ago but
all right so let's say the PlayStation
thing is correct and we start seeing
this do you still think that feels the
right person or maybe he needs to be
replaced at this point in his career to
someone that's a little more aggressive
in terms of the console Market I think
my personal opinion is I still think
Phil's fine uh but I think Phil was one
of the only people that could have did
what he did
to with the brand at the
time um I don't think a lot of people
could have done and moved around the
room the way Phil did in that building
but that being said I can understand the
concept from people where they're saying
we think Phil plays a little bit too
nice and now that he's got all the
tools maybe someone else needs to take
over that is more aggressive kind of
like a Peter Moore all right let me ask
you question no feel is hold up people
saying this is just a convers this is
what you come to the podcast for guys
okay anytime something serious is
rumored like this leadership is always
in
question so we're talking about it I
told you I don't think he needs to go I
think Phil's doing fine but I understand
the concept that people have not
continue Phil has a boss also yeah I
think that's where this is mainly coming
Phil has a boss also if this is true I
don't necessarily think um it's a phield
Spencer decision it could be if if this
is true but like I said Phil has a boss
also man if and his boss is the boss
boss and if he may he say yo Phil like
you remember the Xbox documentary on the
part where they were talking about
mobile um not mobile um motion gaming
Phil
said Bill Gat like yo how do we miss
this motion gaming stuff make a damn
motion gaming device right now the boss
said do it you gotta do it so if this is
true
I mean people say Phil needs to be more
aggressive but I how much more
aggressive is 70 billion right how much
with 70 billion doll I think what's
going to really determine Phil is how he
starts handling when he's when he's
starting to pull ahead because I do
think you know people say wait till next
year wait till next year
2024 you're actually starting to
see this is the future future that
they've been building for the three four
games a year the doublea's between them
like this year is the first year that I
can honestly say this is what they were
talking about for five to six years this
is the reason they bought Bethesda this
is the reason they bought those Studios
this is the reason and I think it would
be irresponsible to get rid of Phil
before he can Captivate on this Vision
because this is Phil's Vision yes to
overwhelm us with content that's his
vision like adct listen man you've been
in this community a long
time you
remember the the mess that F
inherited you know you remember the mess
that field
inherited it was so bad Don matri got
probably asked to resign a month after
E3 2013 Phil is the man I don't want to
hear I see people in in the chat talk
well maybe they need to think think
about doing this with feel he's going to
kill the hardware listen man PE the
stuff is happening right now that people
said would never happen PlayStation is
dropping the game I know they said you
know it's it's a second party deal
because PlayStation doesn't own the hell
diver Studio but they are publishing the
game so they're treating it like first
party people said PlayStation one
wouldn't put games on PC and now since
they put games on PC now they said they
would never do a game on PC day and date
but now they're saying well it's the
games as a service my point is exactly
the industry is changing so people
thinking it's still 2006 you're gonna be
surprised it's not so if in 15 years if
there's no physical Xbox console no
physical PlayStation
console but we're still able to play
games how we
want just deal with it right because bro
I I I hear all of the time people still
thinking it's like the damn early 2000s
or something man it things are not
happening that way there's a different
time I think the part that like annoys
me the most about the whole scenario of
potentially their games going into third
party like that it's like man you just
spent 70 billion on Activision you you
saw some fruits already but thda was
Starfield even though you know I
personally felt like some parts of the
game was underwhelming the game moved
needles yeah it was one of the most sold
things on Steam it it did very well and
I'm sitting here looking at this I'm
like man you know if
only they're doing this before they even
get the marketing rights to Call of Duty
if they are doing it and like to me it's
like I said short-sided you know
shortterm goals It's like because I
believe people look at Call of Duty and
Game Pass Chang and stuff
I don't think people give enough credit
to what
happens when they get their hands on
that marketing
rights because people don't people
always try to act like those marketing
rights ain't relevant they're very
relevant and the fact that they don't
have them right
now I think that's when I would be more
like okay with the third party if
hellblade came out didn't move the
needle uh Elder Scroll 6 came out didn't
move the needle all these game didn't
move the needle they got Call of Duty
put it in Game Pass got the marketing
rights it didn't move the needle but I'm
looking at it from like I understand the
higher ups probably want more of a
return quicker but it's
like this is arguably the best time
Microsoft and Xbox has ever been
in and I would and I'm willing to say
once they get that Call of Duty
marketing rights you're GNA see the
industry start shifting a little bit now
it's not going to be
drastic but
people do not give Call of Duty I don't
like Call of
Duty but Call of Duty comes out in
November and out sells everything the
entire year in 30
days and you don't exception and you
don't think having that game in Game
Pass isn't gonna do
something I don't know like to
me once we do all
that once we do the
hellblade the Elder Scrolls the Fable
and
then if they're like we did it we got to
pull back we got to start putting some
of these games on other platforms I'm
like at least Xbox tried but if they are
considering putting these stuffs on
other platforms before they even loaded
the chamber after they bought them damn
c those damn that damn company that's
what frustrates me the most about the
ideal of
that yeah I mean we we'll see what what
happened all right so you know we're
going to go ahead and and people was
like ad why you uh fake rumors look man
I'm just talking about stuff people are
talking about I get that you guys don't
like when you know certain conversations
happen I don't either but at the same
time me and Dirk gonna just talk about
the stuff that that's going on in the
industry sometimes it's good sometimes
it's bad a member chat from Bunty I got
a backlog I got to catch up on before
all of these Games come out but question
is there any major title coming out
other than first party uh infinite uh
wealth I'm hoping I get a review code
here soon um anything you well Final
Fantasy 7 remake obviously I mean
rebirth I'm gonna play that buy is a bot
though like like no man I'm talking
about you know he said other than first
party yeah
butox he he a bot man that's the homie
he a bot but he didn't say Xbox so I
have to assume he's talking about
everything I got he ask my opinion okay
and my opinion is rebirth looking might
Fine over there okay I think it looks
good I'm not a final fantasy fan but I
think it looks good it's gonna sell
pretty it's gonna definitely sell better
than
16 yeah and then we got the we got the
the member chat from an ominous boss uh
he just became a YouTube member I
appreciate it man appreciate the uh the
put some logos in the chat uh me memb
put put some logos in the chat realm $5
Super Chat from Alvin Alvin ory has a
higher medic than highi rush and that
was fine folks need to relax that is
true they did hit get ory think or a
better game than high five Rush yeah Ori
was pretty good I didn't finish ory
though but I did finish I beat both of
them I think it's a better game doesn't
mean it's uh high five Rush is a bad
game we're we're we're literally just
saying what what Diamond shines the most
I think Alvin point is though people
didn't lose their mind like they are
with high no people
did I don't I remember that people did
people lost their mind over that but
it's it was the switch mentality to my
knowledge or is not on Playstation it's
not yeah so a lot of people's mindset is
we'll play with the switch people but
them PlayStation
ponies don't put it over there we got a
$2 Super Chat from the angry therapist
uh Nintendo needs to give us something
give me Yoshi they ain't gonna give us
nothing because they don't was a damn
thing you know Microsoft play a little
hard ball with them maybe we' get some
but it wouldn't be anything serious I
actually think it would be cool if they
gave us a Mario Kart that they made
Mario Kart with Xbox characters and we
played each other online you know
Nintendo don't do stuff like that they
don't play fair no they selfish it's
ours $2 Super Chat from uh Paul where is
the official announcement stop it we
already covered that one yeah U so let's
get on to the the You could argue that
that was the main event but uh I
wouldn't I would I feel like that was a
good conversation but I want to talk
about this Xbox direct man now put this
time stamp in 52 minutes yeah man make
sure you put the time stamp in you don't
want no stuff on the mafia man the time
stamp Mafia yeah they'll find me you
know I see I think I see someone outside
my window with a shovel so we got you
man okay he's walking away we good he's
walking away make you do it that's all
18th man we're getting another another
direct you gonna be live streaming this
man no this you know it's the second
time work I was supposed to no it's not
even work as my wife man she had
something I had to take her like the
game awards I was supposed to streaming
she had some type of appointment I had
to take her to damn okay I can't do
it soon as it's another show I was supp
the stream she has another appointment I
got to take her to I'm like damn
it so I'm not gonna stream and and I'm
mad about it because I really want to
stream because I streamed it last year
it was fun I really want to stream but
I'm like man damn it bro
so yeah it is what it is at that point
oh my
God uh oh I accidentally knocked out my
uh earphones
oh uh so when it comes to the actual
direct let me uh pull up the uh it's
called Xbox no it's called developer
direct mhm
Xbox yeah returning so let's read this a
little
bit me get the
streamyard present
presenting hey SAS squats s squats don't
you start POS all right can you see this
yes
sir oh you can oh you can blow it up a
little bit
okay
there we go so uh you know I ain't
reading this because you guys know uh
you guys like to make fun of me uh so
I'm not doing that uh so pretty much
what's what's going to be announced here
is Indiana Jones which um is interesting
which I I I I was told that like two
days before it happened so that didn't
catch me off guard as much a
vow Aura history Untold which I hear
it's like a strategy game and I like
strategy games I'm curious is that on
Xbox or is that only on PC I have no
idea I think it's on both someone tell
me someone tell me is it on Xbox or PC
uh and hellblade 2 uh what's interesting
if you read the the way they worded
these these statements up here said we
visit machine games at Sweden to check
in on their Indiana Jones gam swing by
uh obsidian offices see the avowed uh
head to Oxen games Maryland hope to the
AR UNT told and then take a trip to
Cambridge England to see how hell blade
too I feel like they just told us the
order so that means like that yeah yeah
so they they're going to end it with
hellblade if this if I am reading into
this correctly I think you yeah I think
you're on the something right there so
it's kind of interesting they're going
to end it with hellblade uh because if
you
remember they ended last year's with the
game that's coming out
soonest or the biggest game
they yeah the biggest obviously you know
there were games like Minecraft Legends
I don't think that came out uh after red
fall but that game came out came before
redf fall yeah it came out before that
was the biggest title there that was
coming out the soon so I think that's
what's going on here you
know so let me go ahead and in the so
what what do you
think about this lineup do you think
this lineup's good or was there
something that you expected here um
I expected
maybe stalker to to be here but if
they're you know um obviously it's not
maybe the game because I heard that the
game was supposed to drop in the first
quarter or something I don't know but
since it's not it's fine man you know
it's fine because we know they're going
through some crazy stuff over there but
look man yeah to Bourn is another game I
was expecting to see because they H they
say that game supposed to drop soon yeah
and uh jez I didn't see jez say but
someone in the chat J said that coming
out like uh middle of the year or later
half of the year so uh maybe that isn't
getting Shadow dropped but there's any
game to get Shadow drop I think it would
be Tower born yeah apparently double
find's also working on something that
they haven't came out openly and and
came out yet so I'm kind of curious if
that happens as well there's a lot of
things here that you know I feel is very
possible that we could see so I I'm just
curious man I'm curious what what we're
going to see I think I think this is a
great year here to not only be a gamer
to be an Xbox gamer like you know the
amount of games and solid experiences
we're getting this year is is just crazy
but let's let's go through here one by
one and give your expectations of what
you think is going to be what's
interesting is Indiana Jones has more
than 10 minutes of gameplay and
development Insight so 10 minutes of the
show yeah is gonna be Indiana Jones
that's dope man and you know I had
mentioned this in my last video we was
know like if you think about the
timeline with these games and these
Studios you know we think about
Wolfenstein 2 there that game dropped in
2017 right I know they have that little
expansion young blood but their four
their their last full game dropped in
2017 so this is seven years so now it
makes sense that Indiana Jones is
dropping this year and I'm expecting the
game to look great and like didn't why
like was it last year Ty Howard said the
game is like 60 70% done I believe it
was last year yeah he said we'll see you
next year or something yeah in the leaks
it said that that game was coming out
last year so it would make sense because
of it would get pushed to this year yeah
that's that's pretty dope man um that's
incredible
because machine games I'm telling you
guys if you guys I know if you don't
like first-person shooters I don't know
I don't know how Indiana Jones could be
a first- person shooter I really don't
maybe it's going to be a hybrid between
both that's what I'm thinking because
you know sometime he you know climbs on
call it U Traverse or whatever on
mountains and all that stuff I think for
certain puzzles he'll go to first person
for certain puzzles I don't know what I
I think they're gonna you know I just
want this game because look I am not in
the mindset that you can't make an
immersive first person I think you can
machine games is one of the people that
can probably one of the best people that
can machine games does so much immersive
firstperson uh story that I said they
should make the next Halo story not the
multiplayer the story and it doesn't
have nothing to do with the multiplayer
because I always felt like set pieces is
really good for the Halo franchise and
machine games does that stuff good man
like in the first uh in the second one
you're going you're literally on in the
wheelchair like willing your way and
that was at the beginning of the game
too that was fire man that's fire bro I
forgot about that part you rolling in
the in the wheelchair shoot and it shows
you like like it'll get to points where
he he gets back and he and you have to
shoot why he's putting himself on it
yeah yeah it's it's yeah I forgot about
that part so those games are dope man I
didn't really care for the young blood
expansion um but they're a damn good
Studio I can't wait to see man listen
when this studio I mean like when this
year started I was not thinking indana
Jones would
be on the list for 2024 bro that's
that's incredible
have you remember correctly and I ain't
trying to toot my own horn but I have
been on this for a while don't don't
expect if Indiana Jones comes out this
year because of what Todd Howard said
and because of the leaks I've said it
multiple times on ILP I might have even
said it on here I I have I've been very
vocal that it might come out this year
yeah because you think about it when the
game is going to drop the following year
they didn't show it at their showcase
they didn't show it at the VGA or
nothing so it's still a surprise man
it's still a surprise for me all right
so now let's get into a vow uh the team
at obsidian will show the first Deep
dive into gameplay experience fans can
expect in a vow their
upcoming fantasy action RPG set in the
uh uh the Fant I ain't even trying a
vibrant living lands learn more about
how obsidian expertise is building
worlds with deep themes Dynamic game
play so hey cor cor wer said hour to the
show adct a time stamp addict to of his
own
horn
so they're funny they funny they funny
so okay so now that we talking about
that what do you think do you think
they're gonna show like in-depth
gameplay of a vow or do you think it's
going to be one of those things where
they do like a montage I think they're
showing in- depth of all four games
I think they're going to this isn't uh
this isn't a showcase this is a
developers direct they're going to show
they're going to do a deep dive to all
four games because I thought I read this
hour long and it's four games maybe five
games but four games right
now um hey do the math right so yeah I
think it's going to be um I'm looking
forward to a v because we really don't
know much about it all we saw was the
little little little Trader they showed
last year and I'm looking forward to it
man um so yeah I I think this what this
is for to show people about these games
that's dropping this year shout out love
it then we got Arya history unfold uh
you know they there are some vets made
of Studio they uh the vets of uh
civilization 5 and they are there to
unveil their exclusive new gamep playay
uh and share more details and expert
ation key features um I'm a fan of
civilization especially um the
civilization was on the 360 it was like
the more dumb down one because I can
play with my stupid friends and uh you
know I love that game and uh that game's
actually part of backwards compatibility
so I recommend everyone go play that if
you guys want to uh because it's a good
multiplayer for uh a good multiplayer
thing the only real time strategy game
I've ever played was Halo Wars 2 and I
was enjoying it I I I actually figured
out how to play it I was enjoying it um
those C trailers were awesome with with
with uh atrio yeah um but then I
got hard for me one of the most like
memorable scenes of that is when they
first came across Isabelle she's like
the the the orange CI and she's like
she's like what happened here she's like
atrio she like he showed up and he
pretty much said overnight he killed and
took over everyone bro you think about
the beginning of Halo infinite a y put
put them hands on Chief man yeah and
what's funny is there will never be like
even the the funny part is Halo like
Master Chief unless they pick up the
that storyline in the next Halo they're
always going to be
known as Master Chief lost that fight
bro they better continue cuz even even
after you beat Halo infinite no there's
no Redemption and but but it's the tease
you know what I'm saying
because still there yeah yeah they they
try to act like he was dead spoiler
alert from they tried to but at the end
you know spoiler at the end yeah yeah
but uh yeah so I don't know anything
about ARA but listen man I would try any
game at this point especially since it's
on Game Pass I don't have to you know
spend 6070 to try a game I would
definitely try any game I'm not really
into real try that game I'm actually
looking forward to seeing what that game
has to offer it's just like they like I
think civilization cuz I like to play it
with friends and I feel
like my friends don't care unless it's
like a little bit more dumbed down
because civilization is not an easy game
to to pick up so we'll see how that goes
um all right so hellblade 2 Ninja Theory
takes us behind the scenes at their
studio in Cambridge to give us an
insight and how they are crafting
hellblade 2 which
in my opinion D they've been doing that
so maybe they should have worded that a
little bit better the team will speak to
the ambition and Care involved in
creating C's uh journey of
survival uh I do think this is going to
be one of the things they spend the
longest on maybe besides like Indiana
Jones I think you're going to see
different forms of combat in here I
think they're going to everything people
wanted to see you will see in this
showing and I think they showed enough
at the Video Game Awards a little bit
and it got a look couple people off of
them but there's still a lot of people
like I I want to see more what separates
this one from the from the prequel I
think you will get those answers you
might not like the answers but I think
you'll get those answers in this showing
I you know let me say something right
quick if if you played the original hell
blade you've already seen in my opinion
you've already seen enough to to to
differentiate that to the previous game
flat out the first trailer well the
first game play trailer we saw she was
with a bunch of
people that was not happening in the
first one she was always alone except
for with the voices in her head we even
seen in in the uh in like the trailer
they had last month there was still
people with her on certain parts there
was a man like there was a guy like it
was a fight and some guy jumped on one
of the people that she was fighting that
that's one thing right there that's
different from part one part one while I
finished it it was kind of a walking
simulator some parts can get a little
boring part one this one seems
interesting it seems better in every way
to me so far yeah yeah I definitely
agree uh so I think the the biggest
thing here is I think we're going to see
how blade in a way that people want to
see I also think that release that
they're really going to oh let's get
into that actually I think that's the
thing we'll end this with how many of
these games have release
dates I believe hail Blade Two okay I
believe ARA
okay Indiana Jones Okay a won't have a
release date yeah I'm telling you all of
them have release dates oh okay well I'm
rolling with adct y'all
I think all of them are last year all of
them SE fora had release dates yeah I
think all of them are gonna have release
dates okay and I think the reason for is
didn't have a release date is because
they were still unsure of things yeah um
I'd
be what is the what is the lineup in the
order these games come out oh out of
those
four oh man I'm I'm going to
say it's it's
AA yes count
Aura that's a wild card don't know okay
say that one first I'm G say hell blade
next okay I'm say Indiana Jones late
summer and I'mma say AAL is fall okay
I'mma
say hellblade
2 then uh a history
unfold and then AOW and I think Indiana
Jones is the the holiday game okay hey
either way it's fine to me my brother I
think a vow will be like right after
their June showcase like June July
is I love that because I think Indiana
Jones will sell better in the holiday
yeah because even though it's not like a
mad popular IP I think it's still got
more recognition than a vow yeah yeah so
let's see what some people say here uh
AOW hell blade Jones people think a V's
coming out
first I don't think that's the case but
it'll be interesting interesting if
that's the case
yeah we got mot sports for now yeah they
they got some good stuff I think dude
next week G be let them cook with let
them cook with the next Horizon we don't
need one for another in in my opinion
another couple years let them like hey
actually let the whole team go work on
Fable can you imagine what's happening
in 2025 bro oh my God is killing uh so
this individual said it's only a rumor
and you guys are already talk you mean
you guys out I'm so disappointed in you
what you mean you guys I didn't say
way even if you did say that like
literally people people want our
opinions as like content creators
podcasters that's what comes with it
we're speculating you know I'm not
saying that Phil deserves to go because
I feel like there's been very few people
to do what Phil's done I'm saying from a
perspective of seeing what people are
talking about on the internet off of the
conditions that if this rumor is true
because that was the the the key if the
rumor is
true then what are our opinions on it it
don't matter you know what what our
opinions are it's just it's conversation
man if we came in here we just beelined
every topic we started out I'm like yo
yo dir what what you in 2024 you you had
like two sentences I'm like okay what
about third party dirt what about third
party and then you just started a little
about hey hey hey developer direct D
what do you think about the developer
Direct and then you just start like a
sentence and That's all folks and I just
ended the podcast like it's a
conversation man like it's a
conversation relax chat relax we got a$
five Super Chat from uh ice
Rizzo Microsoft wasn't about console uh
gaming instead they wanted to prevent
Sony from taking over the living room it
took 21 years to be all in gaming they
actually pretty much admitted that in a
in a documentary so yeah you're right
about that uh then we got uh shout out
to angry therapist gifted five you
people into the realm man we opened the
per Gat five of you got left in and we
shut that sucker on the rest of
you that's that that's what it is guys I
get it you know I think I do personally
feel like the word doom and gloom is
being used too much these days like just
because we speak about stuff
that that might be a negative aspect of
something doesn't mean like just
speaking what is in the industry right
now what what what the rumors are it
doesn't mean that we're trying to like
get you guys down
like
yeah so what you so like nine Liv did
they like Tim Dog just say
that what he said that Tim Dog said the
rumors are
true oh did Tim just say that I don't
know I'm trying to see just said it or
where you say that at see they we we
fact check in this in this [__] because
the last thing he said is hold on let me
see you guys realize Tim Dog me I can
call Tim dog right now on the phone we I
got his phone
number he didn't say
that yeah I don't see anything yeah I
could call Tim Dog on the phone and be
like they want to know what's going on
oh
man said in the Twitter space Oh
okay so we'll see I mean listen man
we'll see what
happens yeah I feel you scared to answer
the question what was the question hold
up hold up he said he asked me questions
the maunus I think I I probably
butchered your name but it's okay you're
coming at me so uh we enemies for the
time being we when you where's the okay
adct do you buy PS games uh the answer
to that is no the uh IL bu attic uh p ps
games so there you go I do buy PS
games prepare their
anuses no Tim Dog info Tim Dog a good
dude man
yeah oh my God look at adct you know
that can't swim in dirt is black
so is he trying to say black people
can't swim is that a stereotype for
black people I don't know that you
better be black soft
squats oh man I learned everything the
the black community teach me something
every day I didn't know the day
before spider Pan 2 maybe they're
releasing an order they're mentioned in
the announcements Indie avowed able I
would love if a vow came out why that
they did Shadow drop Indiana
Jones n I mean that' be cool but the
odds are very very
slim yeah okay okay nine lies we get it
brother it's
okay okay we get it brother hey but the
thing is didn't like Ninja Theory last
year say um where they had like a thing
in there at at work they had like a play
through at work or something but like
like wasn't something like that they
were watching the game or playing the
game or something um so that was a that
they were done last year you know what
I'm
saying you guys are running away with
every no we're just talking about what's
you know what I ain't gonna keep biting
the chat okay you guys are definitely
you you you are throwing the baits out
and I'm just I'm gobbling them [__]
up so I'm I'm lay told y'all don't want
to talk about it no more but y'all keep
on trying to talk about
it what funny what's funny is you
know these are probably the same
individuals that clowned on Greg for not
want to talk about the Insomniac
Leakes it's like look it's stuff in the
industry we're going to talk about it
that's what we do that's our us as
content
creators it is what it is but uh I
appreciate every coming through man we
had up to 500 people in the chat it's
like I said man you guys rock with me
you know obviously you rock with us man
obviously some sometimes you get mad at
me or you get mad at uh at dirt uh M
mainly me yeah yeah it's mostly you um M
yeah so that's cool man cuz you know I I
could take the hate all right you know I
could take the hate it's cool he ain't
scared of y'all man no I ain't I'm 6
foot4 250 pounds I nah man come at
me catch me
outside nah I I know that uh you know I
get it I get it to a point uh no I have
not played uh Persona 3 Reloaded yet I
don't know if the review codes right I
don't know if I'm getting a review code
we're trying to make a little bit of
leway when it comes to uh when it comes
to like Sega I think we might get a
review code for infinite wealth uh so
we'll see we'll
see yeah so but first off I appreciate
every one of you coming through man you
know you guys show up every week we had
up to like 500 and something people it
it was a blast I gotta get G back on
here g g uh guys will help me keep you
guys tamed keep you guys under
control uh but ie ever coming through uh
DK what you got going on man what you
got going on I'm not Amish okay I just
yes I'm
6'4 I just dropped a video um check that
out you know it's talking about some of
the stuff going on in the community J
Max he's 65 260 I'm I'm 63 300 man we
all some big dudes up in here man let's
go um yeah so I um yeah I I I dropped a
video earlier check it out I think it's
a pretty good video um I have my one man
dark man podcast tomorrow and I got some
merch finally coming out add it some
what some merch merch kind of merch you
willing to share or is that just is that
you ain't got to the point where you
sharing oh I ain't even uh like finished
with it yet but I it's coming posted it
yeah I ain't posted it yet it's like I
got everything ready I kind of want to
get one first for myself before I go
live yeah that makes the most sense you
show off what you're actually
trying to sell yeah because you know I
don't know people gonna buy this [__]
but you know it be you know I think it'
be cool no my face is not on it it's not
a black T-shirt just time say it's a
dirt gy shirt don't even start it I know
what y'all gonna say so you saying it's
a white T-shirt no no it's
[Laughter]
black yeah but check out my last video
that was a white
T-shirt no so check out my last video uh
I think it's a good
video all right so we're going to go
ahead and head out here I'm going to
send you guys over to uh to my stream
I'm probably about go live here in a
couple minutes adct Arena yeah addict
Arena I like the name I do I like the
name so I'm send you guys over there now
if you guys want to go over there and
see me rage uh because because his boss
has been not exactly been the kindest to
me definitely uh stay tuned uh I'm GNA
start that pretty much immediately after
this podcast once again I want to
appreciate everyone coming through we
might disagree but uh you know you guys
you guys put up with my foolishness and
I appreciate that uh this is uh Lord
addict and uh and dark grig and we out
peace
out oh
man